et notre invité politique ce matin cette
année sûrement le Bodo bonjour bon merci
d'être avec nos ministres délégués
chargés de l'organisation territoriale
et des professions de santé vous êtes
également porte-parole d'horizon si elle
partie d'Edouard Philippe on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Julien Lecuyer
de la Voix du Nord bonjour Julien
bonjour William bonjour madame la
ministre bonjour on va évidemment parler
de l'accès aux soins puisque c'est un
sujet qui inquiète beaucoup de Français
mais d'abord quelques mots d'actualité
on l'a entendu hier Gérald Darmanin qui
a donc annoncé un dispositif pour
sécuriser les festivités du 14 juillet
45000 policiers et gendarmes déployés
chaque soir pendant plusieurs soirs il y
a une forte inquiétude au gouvernement
sur la reprise des émeutes il y a une
inquiétude légitime les violences dont
la France a subi il y a quelques jours
on montrait à quel point il était
important que nous puissions réagir fort
et prévenir ces violences les mères sont
parfois inquiets nos concitoyens aussi
sont parfois inquiets et le 14 juillet
c'est dans les villes et les villages
l'occasion de faire nation au 3 de
autour de nos trois belles valeurs
républicaines je crois qu'il est
important que et c'est le rôle de l'État
d'assurer que cette fête puisse se
passer dans de bonnes conditions c'est
pour ça que Gérald de Darmanin hier a
annoncé un plan fort pour permettre à
cette fête de se dérouler le 13 juillet
et le 14 juillet dans de votre défense
ces assurances n'ont pas rassurer les
les communes certaines ont annulé les
festivités ça a choqué un Marine Le Pen
qui estime que c'est un aveu de la perte
totale de la confiance en l'état est-ce
que l'ordre n'est plus garanti en France
et ce qui fait qu'on est obligé de
constater que les communes doivent
annuler les festivités non je crois
qu'il faut d'abord saluer le travail des
forces de l'ordre et de toutes les
forces de l'ordre aussi des pompiers et
aussi le travail des mers qui a été
important pendant ses émeutes je crois
qu'il faut aussi comprendre et entendre
c'est le sens des annonces qui a été
faite qui ont été faites par Dominique
Faure hier même ici au Sénat lors d'une
question au gouvernement il va falloir
travailler aux côtés des mers avec les
mers mais là je le redis le 14 juillet
le 13 juillet dans certaines communes
c'est le bal du 13 juillet pour certains
certains villages c'est l'occasion je le
dis de refaire nation et de faire nation
autour de trois valeurs républicaines le
rôle de l'État c'est d'assurer l'ordre
et le maintien de l'ordre c'est ce qui a
annoncé Gérald delamarin avec ses
mesures fortes et aussi ces mesures
d'anticipation avec la vente et
l'interdiction de la vente et du
transport de des feux d'artifice chez
les particuliers
Emmanuel Macron a décidé de ne pas
s'exprimer à l'occasion de ce de ce 14
juillet alors il l'avait fait en 2020 et
puis en 2022 mais c'est clair c'est pas
une habitude chez lui est-ce qu'il n'est
pas quand même urgent malgré tout de
tirer les leçons de ces événements
tragiques et conclure la période des 100
jours c'est ce qui est manuel Macron a
dit qu'il ferait dans les prochains
jours il ne parle pas toujours le 14
juillet vous l'avez dit vous-même il a
décidé de ne pas parler demain il
parlera dans les prochains jours
à la moitié de la France est parti en
vacances aura la tête bien ailleurs
qu'elle a une déclaration présidentielle
il y a pas un risque que finalement il
parle dans le vide un président de la
République parle rarement dans le vide
enfin en tout cas en tout cas je crois
surtout surtout en ce moment et surtout
après ces moments que vient de vivre
devient de la France
et puis une réaction de votre part on a
appris hier le décès du secteur général
agressé quelques jours plus tôt pas à
son domicile de Vieux Condé dans le Nord
alors ça part des jeunes auquel il
demandait de faire moins de bruit ça
vient après un autre fait divers hélas
aussi tragique dans le dans le Nord à
quesnoy-sur-deule aussi une personne
âgée qui avait été agressée et tué par
pour les mêmes raisons est-ce qu'un
palier n'a pas été franchi dans
l'ultra-violence
les paliers sont franchis depuis de très
nombreuses années je crois que je fais
partie de celles et ceux qui depuis
longtemps dénoncent
l'acceptation que collectivement nous
avons eu face aux violences verbales
comme les violences verbales ne
suffisent pas on passe aux violences
inacceptables et là on parle de la mort
d'un homme donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment être là-dessus très très ferme
très ferme d'abord dans les dans la
réponse au niveau de la justice sur ces
jeunes qui ont qui ont tué un homme faut
clairement le dire et puis
avec sénateur disait juste auparavant
qu'il fallait reprendre la base de
l'éducation en France il y a des mots
que on utilise presque plus souvent au
courant sur le le bonjour Le merci et
puis des mots comme tolérance
bienveillance et respect on s'en doute
malheureusement plus partie des valeurs
que nous employons au quotidien dans nos
relations on ne respecte plus le
policier on ne respecte plus l'agent
d'accueil à la mairie on ne respecte
plus la secrétaire
[Musique]
je pense que c'est important de le faire
et de prendre le temps de l'analyse pour
apporter les bonnes réponses on va
parler de l'accès aux soins vous êtes en
charge on disait de l'organisation
territoriale des professions de santé
une de vos missions c'est de lutter
contre les déserts médicaux l'accès aux
soins c'est un sujet de préoccupation
majeur pour les Français comment faire
en sorte que chaque Français est accès
aux soins écoutez les Français c'est la
préoccupation au numéro 1 de nos
concitoyens le remaniement ils nous en
parle pas du tout donc mais par contre
par contre quand je vais pouvoir faire
pour prendre un rendez-vous chez
l'ophtalmo est-ce que je vais trouver un
dentiste ou j'ai plus de médecin
généraliste c'est le quotidien
de 6 millions de nos concitoyens qui
n'ont pas de médecins donc depuis
maintenant plus d'un an nous avons
construit nous avons d'abord beaucoup
écouté
les territoires les élus les
professionnels de santé et j'ai depuis
le 12 juin l'occasion de proposer quatre
mesures pragmatiques qui vont permettre
de répondre de façon concrète c'est
libérer du temps médical avec 10 000
assistants médicaux qui seront auprès
des médecins en assistant médical c'est
deux consultations par jour de libérer
par médecin pour les recruter donc nous
sommes en train à essayer le plan le
plan il y en a actuellement 4000 donc
ils nous ont encore recruter 6000 pour
arriver au 10000 à fin 2024 donc là un
grand un grand plan a été annoncé aux
côtés de la CNAM j'étais hier à
Fontainebleau avec Marguerite cazena
Cazeneuve pour l'annoncer donc un plan
avec la CNAM les ARS et France travail
pour recruter ces 6000 assistants
médicaux auprès des médecins je le redis
un assistant médical c'est deux
consultations par jour
les médecins c'est le rôle de la CNAM
d'aller vers les médecins pour leur
expliquer tout l'intérêt qu'ils avaient
à embaucher un assistant médical hier
j'étais avec dans une maison de santé à
Fontainebleau avec 5 médecins qui ont
embauché depuis très longtemps un
assistant cervicales ce qu'elles disent
c'est que c'était des femmes médecins
c'est que jamais elle ne ferait machine
arrière donc le tout c'est d'aller
convaincre les médecins et puis aussi de
lever les freins donc on va les
accompagner à l'embauche de cette
assurance médicale on va regarder avec
les collectivités
qui sont obligés de chercher c'est en
médicaux
le package du bouton bouffe voilà on va
les accompagner vraiment parce que nous
pensons que c'est une réponse importante
et c'est un moyen donc libérer du temps
médical j'ai annoncé le 12 juin à
Sisteron un plan de 4000 maisons de
santé pluriprofessionnelle nous en avons
actuellement 2200 donc ça fait 400 par
an à fin 2027 avec un effort financier
de l'État pour accompagner les
collectivités accompagner les porteurs
de projets qui sont parfois des
professionnels à hauteur de 45 millions
mais aussi annoncé là aussi un package
tout près un accompagnement un cahier
des charges
parce que l'exercice pluriprofessionnel
c'est ce que demande les médecins et là
aussi un médecin qui travaille en maison
santé pleurer professionnelle c'est il
voit 160 patients par an de plus qu'un
médecin qui travaille tout seul voilà le
troisième le jeu sur ces maisons de
santé parce qu'il y avait aussi un
engagement du gouvernement est-ce que
chaque Français ne se trouve pas à plus
de 30 minutes d'une maison de santé
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est le cas
est-ce que les Français ont accès
facilement à ces maisons de santé parce
que c'est aussi ça l'enjeu après 30
minutes pour le coup maintenant que je
parcours vraiment beaucoup la France
vous dire que à 30 minutes quand on est
à Paris dans un bouchon je suis pas sûr
que le 30 minutes l'idée il a aussi ce
ministère c'était de renforcer la
proximité c'était ça la promesse avec
ses maisons de santé c'est toujours ça
l'objet c'est de regarder et je suis
ministre de l'organisation territoriale
je ne l'oublie pas c'est de regarder et
c'est bien de faire du coup humain
territoire par territoire c'est vraiment
le la machine que nous sommes en train
d'inverser depuis maintenant un an c'est
avec les territoires pour les
territoires et avec les professionnels
de santé ces projets là lorsqu'ils sont
pensés à l'échelle d'un territoire bah
c'est vraiment important aussi l'objet
du pacte territorial sur lequel le
président de la République nous a
demandé de travailler pour justement
réfléchir à ce que tous ces services
soient bien répartis dans les
territoires et ce qu'on aura le les
médecins en nombre suffisant pour
directement alimenter ces maisons
pluridisciplinaires ces maisons ces
maisons elles ne font elles ne
fonctionnent bien que lorsqu'elles que
lorsque le projet il est construit par
les professionnels eux-mêmes l'idée
c'est vraiment de de les accompagner
pour ça avec les collectivités
territoriales les maires sont très
demandeurs de ces maisons de santé mais
ces maisons de santé elles ne peuvent
fonctionner que si il y a des
professionnels mais une maison de santé
j'étais dans le Puy-de-Dôme il y a
quelques quelques jours
une maison de santé dans un dans une
commune de 800 habitants avec 51
professionnels donc ça marche ça veut
dire que ça attire et à partir de cet
endroit on peut aller vers les communes
aux alentours il y a des endroits où ça
fonctionne il y a plein d'endroits et on
est bien placé dans le
Nord-Pas-de-Calais pour le savoir où ça
ne fonctionne pas les les professionnels
ne veulent pas s'installer pour diverses
raisons vous n'avez pas souhaité aller
plus loin que cela dans la régulation de
l'installation des médecins pourquoi
parce que ça ne marche pas parce que
tout simplement ça ne marche pas il
suffit de regarder ce qui se passe dans
les pays le voisin qui ont impliqué ces
mesures j'étais à Budapest la semaine
dernière
sur une convention organisée par l'OMS
Europe la question numéro 1 que porte
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé au
niveau Europe c'est la démographie
médicale ce problème il est le même dans
tous les pays européens et j'ai pu en
échanger avec avec mes collègues donc
ceux qui ont été vers ces mesures ça ne
marche pas mieux et par contre on sait
que l'effet serait inverse serait
inverse 87% de la France est un désert
médical on ne peut pas réguler lorsqu'il
n'y a pas j'allais dire de matière à
réguler très clairement et puis je crois
qu'il faut aussi écouter ce que nous
disent les jeunes les jeunes nous disent
si vous nous obligez à aller quelque
part où on ne souhaite pas aller on
arrête et la différence entre la
génération d'avant et de maintenant
c'est que maintenant on voit des jeunes
qui sont capables de faire 10 ans
d'études et de faire autre chose et ça
c'est une réalité qui nous faut prendre
en compte par contre je crois beaucoup
à l'incitation et le donner à voir
lorsqu'on invite les jeunes et ce qu'on
leur donne la capacité d'aller faire un
stage dans une commune plus rurale et
bah parfois ils y trouvent un intérêt
parfois j'y trouve un intérêt donc c'est
au cours de du parcours de ces jeunes
médecins ou de ces jeunes professionnels
il faut les les inciter et donner les
conditions pour aller faire les stages
qui est plus de coercition pour
installer les médecins disons que le
désert médical les désert médicaux c'est
un carburant pour le rassemblement
national
la réponse au service public c'est un
carburant pour mais le rassemblement
national n'apporte pas de réponse non
plus sur ce sujet n'apporte pas de
réponse non plus sur ce sujet c'est une
mauvaise réponse et tout le monde le
sait la régulation ça veut dire ça
voudrait dire quoi retirer un
professionnel d'un territoire où il y
aurait moins de plus de professionnels
pour le mettre dans un comment vous
comment vous expliquer ça et comment
vous gérez ça ça n'est absolument pas
possible et en plus ça ne marche pas et
ça aurait je vous le redis les effets
contraires vraiment les effets
contraires et ça nous en sommes
intimement convaincus pour avoir regardé
ce qui se passe à l'étranger pour avoir
beaucoup échangé avec les professionnels
et d'ailleurs l'Assemblée nationale a
rejeté cette idée
plutôt massivement d'ailleurs parmi les
vos autres mesures il y a la question
des médicaments bus parce que vous
travaillez aussi beaucoup sur le aller
vert à l'époque comme on dit maintenant
il y a dit médicobus qui sont en
circulation vous envisez 100 c'est d'un
peu en réalité de la première ministre
d'ici fin 2024 comment on passe de 10 à
100 on va d'abord lancer un premier
appel à projet
en septembre avec l'objectif à fin mars
2024 de 30 nouveaux médicobus là aussi
c'est un travail partenariat avec les
collectivités territoriales je connais
des départements qui sont très
intéressés pour développer ce dernier
kilomètre comment on va vers les
citoyens dans le Gers j'ai pu aller voir
un don tobus ou à la on avait un modèle
intéressant c'est un dentiste qui va
dans les paysages une fois par mois
c'est un dentiste retraité avec deux
jeunes internes de jeunes internes
dentistes qu'il a aussi développent et
découvre la France en tout cas le Gers
grâce à ce dontobus mais c'est le
dernier kilomètre comme à partir d'une
maison de santé dans un territoire des
médecins peuvent aller faire des
consultations c'est un médecin retraité
ce que vous avez vous trouvez les
professionnels en nombre suffisant là
aussi pour pour équiper ces médicaments
c'est l'objet du travail il y en a un
dans l'ordre qui fonctionne très bien et
qui organisé par les professionnels de
santé eux-mêmes d'ailleurs qui qui gère
comment vous leur vendez le projet il y
a des découvrir
la France est belle moi je vous l'assure
et aussi
vous le savez très bien
la France
c'est un mode d'exercice complètement
différent on découvre on découvre des
des situations humaines dans chaque des
pathologies on accompagne des jeunes moi
j'ai trouvé que le modèle avec le
médecin le dentiste retraité et ses
étudiants étaient assez extraordinaires
en soi c'était porté par la Croix-Rouge
ça bouge vous êtes en charge d'un autre
sujet là aussi qui intéresse beaucoup
les Français c'est la fin de vie est-ce
que le texte sur la fin de vie sera
présenté d'ici le 21 septembre le
président de la République le 3 avril
dernier suite aux travaux que la
convention citoyenne lui a remis a été
très clair il a demandé au gouvernement
de présenter un texte avant la fin de
l'été le 21 septembre au Conseil des
ministres ce texte nous sommes en train
de le de l'écrire de le co-construire
avec un groupe de parlementaires de
continuer à écouter les soignants il
sera présenté sur le bureau du Conseil
des ministres avant le 21 septembre
avant la fin de l'été pour un examen ça
difficile de le savoir pour l'instant ça
on va attendre l'agenda parlementaire de
la rentrée je ne l'ai pas en tête en
tout cas le travail d'écriture de ce
texte du projet de loi de la fin de vie
avec l'ouverture d'une aide active à
mourir des soins palliatifs et tout un
travail sur le droit des patients sera
bien déposé avant la fin de l'été et
juste Emmanuel Macron il a parlé quand
il a conclu la convention citoyenne d'un
modèle français de la fin de vie il est
resté un peu vague est-ce que dans ce
texte figurant les termes de suicide
assisté d'euthanasie je vous dis nous
sommes en train d'écrire d'écrire ce
texte dans le modèle d'accompagnement
français de la fin de vie je l'ai dit
lors de mes déplacements aucun modèle à
l'étranger aucun modèle n'est duplicable
in extenso pour des tas de raisons mais
dans ce modèle d'accompagnement de la
fin de vie je crois qu'il faut prendre
tout ça dans sa globalité avec la
volonté de développer les soins
palliatifs ça c'est ça fait partie de
l'accompagnement et puis l'ouverture de
ce nouveau droit sur lequel nous sommes
en train de travailler et ça veut dire
vous inscrirez pas forcément ces mots
dans le texte initial je vous dire oui
je vais pas revenir nous sommes en train
d'y travailler et d'y réfléchir et vous
savez que j'ai aussi lancé le travail
sur le le poids des mots parce qu'on
sait que certains mots peuvent choquer
mais mais les mots ont un sens et c'est
ce travail nous le menons aussi parce
que je pense que c'est aussi important
de le mener en même temps il y avait
dans l'idée aussi de d'avoir une loi
avec quand même des restrictions est-ce
que vous ne pouvez nous rappeler
lesquels en particulier le président de
la République le 3 avril dernier a très
clairement fixé des lignes rouges la
ligne rouge c'est pas les mineurs les
modalités d'accès à cette aide activée
c'est un pronostic vital engagé à moyen
terme et puis
le court terme dans le dans le la loi
qui laisse le nity était défini c'est le
moyen terme c'est
en Oregon c'est 6 mois voilà les travaux
avec la même chose en France
et puis après la capacité de travailler
par des grès et de réfléchir est
important le court terme dans la loi
classe lionity était a été défini après
quelques jours à quelques semaines
quelques jours quelques semaines
regardons ce qu'a fait l'Oregon et je
pense que ce sont les soignants qui sont
les mieux placés pour dire ça veut dire
quoi le moyen terme
l'échelle entre 6 et 12 mois paraît
quelque chose quelque chose qui soit
acceptable François brun le ministre de
la Santé qui est votre Ministre de
tutelle dit que c'est un problème de
société pas un problème médical et que
ce n'est pas le rôle de médecin de faire
ce type de geste qu'est-ce que vous en
dites je dis que sur ce sujet chacun a
le droit d'avoir son avis c'est un
effectivement un sujet un sujet de
société ce sont les débats que nous
avons et c'est pour ça que nous
continuons à travailler à écouter les
soignants
c'est difficile il y a des il y a des
grosses réticences
il y a des positions qui sont connues
d'ailleurs et qui s'expriment et c'est
légitime
vous pouvez faire un texte pareil contre
la vie des soignants on fait jamais un
texte contre on construit un texte
on écoute et puis au moment c'est le
gouvernement prendra sa responsabilité
un seul professionnel peut dire que le
pronostic vital est engagé c'est le
médecin
et la première des réponses à ça c'est
comme cela a été fait au moment des
discussions sur l'IVG c'est la cause de
conscience spécifique et là il y a aucun
doute sur le fait que la clause de
conscience spécifique fera partie du
texte de loi ça c'est ça c'est évident
vous soulevez le dossier de l'IVG qui
avait donné lieu à des affrontements
assez violents à la à l'Assemblée
nationale on se souvient que les lois de
bioéthique souvent sont le théâtre de
voilà de débats animés est-ce que vous
attendez un débat serein sur ce sujet
alors je pense qu'il y a pas eu
d'affrontement il y a eu des débats
dans l'assemblée
moi je me souviens très bien puisque je
préside la cosmission spéciale des
révisions de loi de bioéthiques lors de
la dernière
législature que ces débats se sont
passés de façon apaisée il y a des
débats c'est un sujet de société et
c'est normal je fais beaucoup de débats
partout j'étais à Strasbourg lundi soir
j'ai été vraiment très surprise par la
teneur et la tenue des débats les gens
sont capables de s'écouter et puis le
meilleur exemple c'est ce qu'a fait
c'est ce qu'on fait les 184 citoyens de
la convention citoyenne ils ont beaucoup
travaillé mais ils ont travaillé en
s’écoutant et en se respectant moi j'ai
aucun doute sur le fait que il y aura
des débats mais que les débats se
passeront j'allais dire de façon et
c'est énorme et le texte et le sujet le
vaut et le mérite
donc vous avez installé le 1er juin
d'instance de réflexion stratégique sur
le plan décennales pour les soins
palliatifs vous avez une réunion
aujourd'hui pour faire un premier un
premier bilan est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire quelques mots est-ce qu'on
tiendra les délais est-ce qu'on va enfin
pouvoir vraiment avancer sur cette
question essentielle là aussi je le
redis le volonté du Président de la
République et la première ministre
c'était de d'abord de comprendre
pourquoi après plusieurs plans
quinquennaux nous n'arrivions pas à
avancer plus sur sur les enjeux des
soins palliatifs qui sont un véritable
enjeu d'accompagnement de la fin de vie
nous avons fait le choix de travailler
sur une stratégie sociale justement pour
se projeter parce que l'enjeu majeur
c'est la formation La formation des
professionnels est de tous les
professionnels c'est de prendre en
compte le domicile on nous demande
beaucoup d'aller à domicile donc le
développement des unités mobiles de
soins palliatifs de prendre en compte
les soins palliatifs pédiatriques ça ce
sera une nouveauté par rapport à ce qui
existait avant et puis la première des
réponses et ce qu'attendre de nous la
majeure partie de nos concitoyens c'est
l'égalité d'accès et donc faire en sorte
que tous les départements français soit
dotés d'une unité soit palliatif mais il
y aura plein d'autres mesures je vais
pas vous dire ce qui va me présenter
dans quelques temps maintenant je ne
sais pas une dernière question un peu
plus politique ce matin dans une grande
interview Figaro Laurent Wauquiez tant
la main à Emmanuel Macron il l'appelle à
l'union sacrée il demande au chef de
l'État de faire une forme d'union sacrée
il faut dépasser temporairement les
divisions il veut un accord sur les
grands textes c'est ce qui est manuel
Macron Élisabeth band doivent saisir
cette main tendue je crois que Elisabeth
borne est le président de la République
ont déjà tendu la main au début du
quinquennat qui a été refusé et le
travail a été fait texte par textes
Laurent Wauquiez dit déjà temporairement
donc j'ai vu le titre du journal les
exigences je pense que quand on souhaite
discuter on commence pas par avoir des
exigences et on parle pas de
temporairement si la volonté de discuter
elle est là elle est bien réelle je
pense qu'on peut faire ça de façon un
peu plus ouverte et un peu plus souple
je le redis la volonté de travailler
avec les parties de l'arc républicain la
main était tendue au début du
quinquennat elle a été refusée si
certains souhaitent vu la situation
difficile dans laquelle nous sommes
travailler texte par texte c'est ce qui
a été fait d'ailleurs 43 ans
sur lesquelles vous pourriez vous mettre
d'accord mais j'ai pas vu l'article et
j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai vu le titre j'ai
trouvé ça un peu façon cavalière de
vouloir rentrer dans des discussions
mais je crois que d'abord c'est au
président de la République et à la
première ministre de travailler sur ces
sujets mais on va voir Philippe il peut
pas ouvrir un rapprochement entre les
républicains et la majorité président
tout le monde peut faire un
rapprochement avec les parties de l'arc
républicain
mais c'est c'est nécessaire et de toute
façon vous le savez très bien dans le
cas d'une majorité relative il est
important de pouvoir trouver des
majorités textes par textes mais c'est
aussi bien de de voter de respecter ces
engagements
c'est une bonne idée ou pas
je ne ferai pas de commentaires sur
cette et je vous dis en fait nos
concitoyens en fait je vous dis partout
en France
c'est pas ce qu'il est c'est la réponse
à leurs besoins qui les interpelle c'est
pas le remaniement et c'est pas qui sera
à Matignon demain ou après-demain et
Elisabeth borne est là et elle vient de
travail merci Agnès sûrement le modo
regarde la Une de La Voix du Nord un
parfum d'été elle a une de la Voix du
Nord
en effet les festivités près de chez
vous je vous souhaite un bel été du coup
Julien un très bel été merci merci
à vous merci d'avoir été notre invité on
passe au club des territoires